when I see these little kids I ask
myself one day she's going to be a mom
one day she's going to be telling
stories to her kids what kind of stories
is she going to be telling she's going
to be telling them these people blew
your uncle's legs off these people
killed your grandma here's the video of
me 30 years ago crying in the street and
what do you think that kid's going to do
mhm that's my mom that you guys crying
covered in mud like this crying in a
hospital covered in mud right and
there's no one there crying for for
minutes on and no one to hold her no one
to hug her no one to put a blanket on
top of her and the only adults around
her are equally devastated so how do you
think that kid's going to feel marketing
cannot penetrate the home you can Market
you can lie you can cover things over
you can pretend they don't exist you're
not going and changing people's homes